president biden says he's trying to take
another bite out of russia's struggling
economy he's calling for the u.s to join
european allies in stripping russia of
its preferential trade status
deborah alfredon has the latest on this
from the white house deborah good
morning jeff this morning we're hearing
that french president emmanuel macron
and also german chancellor olav schultz
are speaking right now with russian
president vladimir putin president biden
yesterday decided he was going to
release some more sanctions effectively
crippling the russian economy all in a
show of support for ukraine
putin is an aggressor he is the
aggressor and putin must pay the price
president biden delivered another
crushing economic blow to russia friday
revoking russia's trade status means no
more imports of russian goods like
seafood vodka and diamonds costing
vladimir putin's regime a billion
dollars in annual revenue as putin
continues his merciless assault the
united states and our allies and
partners continue to work in lockstep
to ramp up the economic pressures on
putin and to further isolate russia and
a global stage this latest action
affects the russian oligarchs who are
putin allies no more high-end
american-made luxury items like watches
cars and designer clothes they support
putin they steal from the russian people
and no more access to cash through the
international monetary fund and the
world bank it is deeply troubling russia
called a last minute meeting of the u.n
security council friday falsely accusing
americans of developing chemical weapons
inside ukraine the u.s quickly denounced
that as a false flag saying russia's
lies could be a way to detract and
justify their own potential use of
chemical weapons we're not going to let
russia get away with lying to the world
or staining the integrity of the
security council by using this forum as
a venue for legitimizing putin's
violence
russia would pay a severe price of these
chemicals
ukraine said yesterday that russia is
preparing something called a false flag
operation saying that they plan to
create a man-made catastrophe at the
chernobyl power plant which they now
control and then blame it on ukraine
president biden said yesterday that
russia needs to get out of there and
leave that site calling their actions
quote profoundly irresponsible and
dangerous jerica
deborah alfred a lot of information
coming in by the hour thank you